High school is the foundation for the rest of your life.
There's only one chance at first impression to work hard.
Put your heart out there, and don't go into high school without backup.
You need to stick together to survive.
Got it?
*ALL NOD*
One last thing. Don't blow Monse
*ALL LAUGH*
High school is an app for reinvention.
Mamacita!
Bitches be bonkers
Loyalty Trump's victory call five minutes
Ruby I see you and I'm down with it. I like the freaky
Baby
What happened with sticking together you don't understand this life. It's my destiny it's to it
How are we going to survive high school
You please break down what's going on? It's complicated. We're dysfunctional understatement
We don't even look it's Brentwood if nothing bad happens you how about OJ, no offense Jamal? Go. I'm good. We don't claim him
You